it's great to welcome back it to the
program Jason Stanley who's a professor
at Yale University author of the books
how fascism works the politics of us in
them and how propaganda works both very
very relevant in 2019
Jason so great to have you back on great
to be back on David so a couple of
things that I want to touch on I mean
one generally speaking you know we we
explored the idea in your first
appearance on the show about how there
are sort of very formal characteristics
and definitions of things like fascism
but that often times in practice in
ostensibly democratic Western
governments elements of fascistic
behavior can sort of creep in it's not
fascism per se but that doesn't mean
that it's not a useful term to explore
what it is that we're seeing how
relevant is that as a lens through which
you continue to watch the Trump
administration since you were last on I
think it's it's highly relevant I mean
what we're seeing is we're seeing a
continued co-optation of our
institutions so we're seeing a we're
seeing institutions that are supposed to
be independent but are being transformed
into essentially loyalty cadres of
loyalists for the the leader which is
what we see in the devolution and
deconstruction of democratic in in
countries in Eastern Europe Poland and
Hungary primarily we're seeing our
courts being co-opted by partisan
extremists so this is this is we're
seeing a one-party state developed we're
seeing and the one plan it's not just a
one party state filled with decent
Republicans committed to a multi-party
system it's a party being taken over by
a family and a leader and we're seeing
and we're seeing taken over by partisans
of that party so that is something
deeply worrisome we're seeing that
accelerate
the courts are going to be in the hands
in very partisan hands for some number
of time we're seeing an accelerate we're
seeing a toleration a greater toleration
for things that seemed shocking
two years ago so ice the situation at
the border and in the detention centers
we're seeing people we're seeing the
normalization of treatment of our fellow
human beings people are learning to look
away and that of course is a very
disturbing sign of encroaching fascism
when we talk about the Trump presidency
there are a couple of different views
that that are still critical but they're
different views that can sometimes be
applied one is that this is sort of an
anomaly and that as soon as Trump is
gone everything goes back to how it was
before for better or worse we can debate
how it was before but it immediately
sort of goes back the other idea is that
Trump now has modified what is
considered acceptable for the office of
the presidency in a way that will not
simply go back to the way it was even
once Trump personally is gone what what
does history tell us about that what
what are you what are your thoughts
about that right well we have we are so
sorry
democracy is held up by norms that that
in even in the best instance are not
followed but at least you have to pay
loyal
lip service to them now we're not paying
lip service
even to those norms anymore so we're
seeing an assault on truth that is
unprecedented it's not that governments
didn't our government didn't lie to us
government's lie governments lie that's
what they do
liberal liberal different democracies
lie to their people government's lie the
Iraq war financial crisis our racial
history filled with lies but it's
something different now there's a
different character to the lying so in
the past take the Iraq war there was an
intent to deceive if you looked at the
literal statements the literal
statements were not as often
why's they were just they were meant to
mislead you trick you into thinking you
know rum so say Saddam Hussein it's not
an honest man and well that could be
true consistently with Saddam Hussein
not being involved in 9/11 okay and so
they were intense to deceive there's no
more intent to deceive there's just
bald-faced open lying an assault direct
assault on truth and so that is very
particular to authoritarians
authoritarians try to dismantle truth
and make the public space information
space just us versus them so so what
we're seeing now is is them don't they
don't believe the things that Trump says
but they think it's it's are lies versus
their lies there's no reality there's no
cost for lying anymore and so and and
it's just you're with us or work or
against us and that's anti-democratic
because democracy is all about
compromise it's about seeing our fellow
citizens point of view not vilifying our
fellow citizens so our information space
has been really damaged and I'm not
exactly sure how we repair it is that
one of the the hallmarks of effectively
propagandizing by a government or
administration that even when the
followers the recipients of the
propaganda identify that on a on the
basis of facts what they're being told
isn't true they either accept it on the
assumption that there's some greater
truth that is implicit or even sometimes
on the idea that the end sort of justify
the means or that the other people also
lie like is that a sign that you are
effectively propagandizing your
followers yes definitely but it's a
particularly kind of propaganda all
political parties engage in propaganda
no what's tricky is to notice the
difference in our information space the
difference is not that people are
manipulating audiences with rhetoric
that's just called politics and so the
right do it the left do it the Democrats
there
everybody but what's different is that
there's no intent to make people believe
things believe that reality is different
than it is it's just an attempt I mean
there's no there's no attempt to to to
sort of give plausible sounding reasons
it's just churning the political space
into complete us-versus-them this is why
the subtitle of my book how fascism
works is the politics of us mmm this is
what you see when you see the attacks on
democracy and if you couldn't remember
previous admit your self back to the pre
Trump era if that's even possible across
now uh it was a time where we knew that
our politicians lied to us but we also
knew that if you caught them there would
be a cost that's gone uh we now have the
situation that you used to have that I
would understand from people who lived
under authoritarian regimes where
everywhere everyone thought everybody's
lying it's all one big lie you just have
to figure out as you said who's really
deeply on your side and the distinction
between a deeper truth and let's
remember and and and a superficial truth
is one that is comes from the Soviet
Union that that Pravda is the deeper
truth and so the state might lie on the
service to a deeper truth and that's the
the emblematic of authoritarianism if
you can remember back to like 2012-2013
you know there were real costs to lying
there were real costs to being caught in
a lie because this deeper truth element
wasn't that the area when we look at
some of the different areas you
mentioned at the beginning so for
example Donald Trump doesn't literally
control the judiciary in the way that
you see in some other countries but he's
responsible for having selected more and
more Supreme Court justices more and
more lower I don't know
level judges so it's not a direct
control in in the cartoonish way that
sometimes exist but he is exerting more
and more influence over the judiciary
Trump doesn't literally control the
media but there are some media outlets
that are essentially arms of the Trump
administration there are others that
even in their critiques of Donald Trump
are still being led almost by a leash as
to what will you talk about for the next
four days when Donald Trump decides to
tweet about a to take your attention off
of B so in looking at all of these
different areas that Donald Trump is not
in a formal sense controlling but is
increasingly wielding influence over
which is the most concerning to you in
terms of its authoritarian direction
that it's going
the judiciary okay ah I mean the media
is well both are concerning but it's
more the judiciary the Republican Party
unfortunately the the moderate
Republicans that we remember from times
past are fewer and fewer and the ones
that desire power at all costs a
one-party state complete domination I
mean you know we have to remember this
president lost by three million votes
that anti-democratic elements in the
structure of our country like the
electoral college and the whole system
of the Senate really that disempower
majorities are are at work here and then
we have an assault on voting rights and
the the Supreme Court validating
partisan extreme partisan gerrymandering
so at some point you have to ask in what
sense are we a democracy or even I mean
there's always oh we're not a democracy
we're a republic or what sense are we
anything but a one-party state and the
judiciary has been now filled with very
young far right many of them partisan
hacks and so when you look at the
literature on authoritarianism they
always warn you about a one-party state
and if you look at our gb2 judiciary
what we're seeing is a lot of partisan
hacks a lot of people who are not
trained at elite elite
stands who who are basically from not
that elite institutions have always led
us in the right way
mind you and of course the Supreme Court
is and the elite institutions are part
of the problem the Supreme Court on the
right and the left on whatever ideology
they're all from Harvard and Yale yes so
but but we have a lot of unqualified
justices and people who are just part
really really partisan and so that
deeply concerns me it's flying under the
radar these are people who are gonna
steer policy for decades to come and I
don't know how much of this can be
undone
so I really worry about the guts of our
democracy the voting laws the Voting
Rights Acts has been gutted partisan
gerrymandering has been validated so if
you go back to Jim Crow well what was
Jim Crow about but about the voting
system and there's a lot of concerns
about our voting system and the
judiciary is really foundational there
so even if you have a fully free cross
that can say what what it wants
ultimately it's supposed to affect the
voting system and if the voting system
is not free and fair then we're going to
increasingly I have problems so if
Donald Trump is reelected in November of
2020 which I mean I'm not making any
predictions at this point but it's
certainly quite plausible despite you
know hearing oh he's not doing well in
North Carolina okay listen we know that
our expectations the day before Election
Day are often proven wrong if he is
allowed to no longer have another
election coming up what concerns do you
have about what the next level maybe in
these authoritarian tendencies like what
has he not done yet that at this point
he could probably get away with uh he's
shown a clear proclivity towards using
the the instruments of power to target
his enemies bill Barr the Attorney
General has proven to be a very
dangerous person so the thing is that
he's got an attorney general who seems
to believe
the presidency is a dictatorship and so
Ben bill Barr is now opened a criminal
investigation on the basis of a
far-right conspiracy about how Ukraine
supposedly sat Putin up yep so that's
already extremely disturbing and it's a
year away from the election to open up a
criminal investigation on the basis of a
far-right extremist conspiracy that
Ukraine somehow was setting up so using
the instruments of power using the
Justice Department he's a very willing
Attorney General to target political
opposition he seems to think that's
completely fair we already are starting
to look like a banana then asked the
dynastic banana republic I mean he
brings his family members are at all
loci of power so you know these pictures
from the g20 and and these other with
with Ivanka Trump and and various other
family members just it's just so we're
looking already like a family dynasty
we're seeing the Justice Department
being used to target political opponents
were we're seeing I'm extremely worried
about the ever-increasing intensity of
the immigration mechanisms which are
sending our fellow residents in the
United States into hiding no mercy at
all and he seems to not be able to find
a Department of Homeland Security had
whose harsh enough so so I'm worried and
I'm worried about these mechanisms of
cruelty being baked into our economy as
you already see in the Midwest where
many county jails rely on the money they
get from ice so you you have really
harsh targeting of undocumented of
undocumented workers and residents so
I'm worried that the gloves will be off
in a way that even now is hard to
imagine
we've been speaking with Jason Stanley
who's a professor at Yale University he
is the author of
the most recently the author of two
books how fascism works the politics of
us and them and also how propaganda
works Jason so great having you on again
great to speak to you David